so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody I am Thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me I
am here with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up folks what up stop use your
podcast we're gonna talk about life
drugs problems accomplishments and
everything in between guys we have a
very special guest today today's guest
from Pittsburgh Chevy Woods how you
doing man I'm great how are you I'm good
I'm good first thing and first thing
much taller than that bro
I recognize that right away probably
because I saw the video of him dunking
though that was one of the earlier
everybody says that I mean I'm we you
know we meet a lot of short rappers
being tall so everybody's like I didn't
expect that well everybody goes to me
like yeah you're pretty small
what I tell you bro what are you like
six five six seven six four okay and
real quick uh my homies told me to ask
I'm randomly I have so many friends in
Pittsburgh uh Ryan DJ after thought the
whole little all the homies over there
they asked me Justin Boyd had called him
right before we started I'm like dude
what am I what am I asking them
personally goes I don't know he's good
at bowling yeah
I just seen him out not too long ago too
uh yeah I mean bowling was a thing that
it was like I used to go to I I didn't
like it back then um I used to go to my
aunt's house on Sundays and during the
we started to get into like Sunday
school and uh Bible study vacation and
stuff like stuff that you didn't really
care about for real back then but we
would go bowling you know what I mean so
that was like the highlighted thing and
I had a homie named Delvin Peaks and he
was a little older than me and I seen
him do the how to curve and spin and
that's when they just clicked back then
do all that [ __ ] yeah you ever hit a 300
game before nah 289. oh every good
bowler right now goes
it was so crazy because this short story
I hit all the strikes and then I got to
the last one and wiz was like and I
turned around and with everybody was on
my Lane watching like waiting for me to
throw this ball on Wheels was like don't
shake nobody's hand just keep doing what
you were doing the whole time so when I
threw the last strike
OT Genesis was like yeah boy yeah and he
did like that and so they did like that
I threw the ball and I missed one pin so
I was like [ __ ] that's a Malcolm in the
Middle [ __ ] I don't know if you I know
you ever watched it too much but that's
the Malcolm in the Middle yeah it was
jinxed yeah for sure all right so
straight off the bat Sports this we'll
say it over here New York's number one
shooting guard of all time because he
only shot one three but he made the
[ __ ] fire he made it 100 100 shooter
over here now you get to say it's
nothing perfect but my jump shot and
Floyd Mayweather's boxing record exactly
I've been living vicariously through
that jump shot ever since like [ __ ]
20 years sorry right real quick you just
got off a tour with whiz and logic how
long was that one
um I think like a month and some change
maybe a month in like a week or two
weeks straight yeah I mean six days a
week one day on Monday do you come home
at all no damn people say they're going
on tour and then they do four shows in a
month yeah yeah I've caught a run yeah
six nights in a week yeah it was crazy I
mean some days we get two days off you
know what I mean um
it was cool though I mean except for
being 6'4 and sleeping in a bunk you
know what I'm saying so all boss all bus
damn bus work oh this is a this is crazy
bro
I like you smoke weed for real because
everyone that does always has to do this
make sure you got no hard Spots You're
gonna [ __ ] your whole joint up you know
what's up all right it has to anytime I
get a joint in my hand or if I roll it
or anything it has to fit the way that
I'm gonna smoke that's what I'm doing
right now yeah I rolled this [ __ ] I'm
still doing it like it's got a paper
like over top no because these are white
tips yeah
I'll push the paper that's why I did on
this one look I ripped that [ __ ] off
hey you know what's up all right cool um
so real quick question for someone
that's been on tour for a while
and prior to quarantine is there a big
difference
um yeah uh I feel like I mean the
language is different backstage where
you can't have as many people as you
would like to and stuff like that and
for some people the test was there for
you to take every day covet tests damn
but I'm not one of those people that's
about to run to it like every day or
whatever you know make the whole staff
do it every day type of [ __ ] yeah so
certain situations where you have to
then there's certain situations where
you just like uh whatever I'll do it
next time yeah so if the language was
different the the I mean the feeling was
the same because I feel like after a
couple shows got a little lenient
towards like letting people and hang out
and stuff like that so I feel like that
went out the window a little like
towards the end of it but at the
beginning it was like very serious and a
few people you know I don't necessarily
know if it was coveted or not but a few
people got sick on tour so yeah I work
with a lot of Comedians and it really
like shined a light on who has a real
fan base because when he had to come off
the road you had to really lean into
your fan base and to just you know to
keep your career going basically did you
find it as like did you come out of that
whole situation as like as far as your
career goes like damn I'm actually
stronger coming out of that because it
forced me to kind of pivot because we
read that you just dropped a project
right before it right
so for me I feel like
um something that was special for me I
dropped my first album in the pandemic
like first real studio album oh no [ __ ]
and I didn't get to go out and perform
none of the records at that time so now
this time I just went back and I was
doing the records from off of the album
so it got me like a new group of fans
because they never heard me perform
Escape or the song Alive or nothing like
that so it was kind of different for
them and a different sound yeah exactly
so seeing me not just go up there and
rap and seeing me go up there and
actually had a mic stand and singing and
you know with the words out of it like
you know a lot of people record you know
yeah but this time I wanted to take
advantage of knowing my lyrics knowing
how the song supposed to be performed
and stuff like that so I was just up
there basically in school again teaching
myself
that's it so that kind of gave you time
to like prepare and get better and
actually made the roll a lot better yep
usually it's the first like full studio
album you've done is is it more mainly
just like smaller projects you've been
putting out over the years yeah so I put
out a I mean you know we started to use
the language of like projects and went
away went away from kind of the mixtape
word but at the same time that I put out
like what 18 19. damn projects since
I've been doing this you know what I
mean so to actually go in the studio and
really work on an album and put
everything else that's a mixtape or
anything else aside like I wasn't even I
wasn't even taking people's like
features when I was working on the album
because it was just something different
for me I didn't want no other sounds I
didn't want to know none of that I
wanted the homies Insight that I'm
around and what we're doing in the
studio how long did you take to record
it
um
honestly
to I mean I went back I went back and
grabbed a few songs that were like a
year or two prior so I mean maybe like
four to six months but I've been working
on it forever wanting to do it but I
just had to find the right side of the
place and how many producers were
involved
um I think I think it was light this
time I think it was only like six lights
that's a lot it's still a lot light
light like light like like
producers you know what I mean like some
of them did two or three gotcha so
that's what I mean like it was only a
couple of them that's cool man do you
have somebody that you've like worked
with for a long time that you always
kind of are like you know randomly in
the studio with all the time or do you
normally just kind of have a bunch of
different people you work with
um sledrin uh Ricky P my boy germ
um my new homie that I'm doing a project
with right now
um his name is Mike Vegas he's from the
Ukraine so when all that [ __ ] was going
on while I was like recording my while I
was uh I just put out the project big
wood season but all this [ __ ] was going
on over there he hit me with a text and
was like yo I'm not even gonna be out my
house for the next two three months
like I can't leave with all the war
stuff that's going on so he was over
there going through that and still
sending me music and [ __ ] like that you
know what I mean so like that gives you
like a motivation to say you know I
can't quit and at the same time I want
to help him so he did a couple songs on
the project and then I was like you know
what I want to do a whole project with
you and it's just me I want to do I love
his production but I want I want him to
get the look that he's supposed to get
as well yeah so because she bring people
up when you see it yeah I love to see
that that's like I'm from Buffalo so
like for like riselda and Derringer like
they have their own sound like they can
go and work with a bunch of different
producers but at the end of the day that
is their sound they formed over time
like right something special love that
sound by the way yeah another question
about the tour you said this is the
first time you're really on stage
performing those songs that you didn't
get to perform how'd you how'd you like
this because it's a different you know
it's a different feel you know when
you're on the bill like you it's you
like oh [ __ ] everyone this is my [ __ ]
album I'm playing right it was a I mean
I was nervous at first
um I'm so surprised to hear that you
still get yeah you still get it well it
didn't really that's the first time in a
while you know what I mean because I was
going with the song out and I'm
particular about how my voice sounds to
people over big speakers you know what I
mean so that's where I went to the
studio I hit my engineer his name is
Aaron and I was like yo send me the
track with the with the [ __ ] out of it
and I made sure that the sounds good the
sound guys on tour had the right
auto-tune so we got the whole session
from when I actually did it
and we brought it on tour a while so I
was able to just mimic exactly what I
did in the studio so it made it kind of
easier after the fact but the first two
shows bro I was singing with the words
in bro I was [ __ ] oh it's got to be
hard to like sound right exactly and
then I wasn't using any errors so like
not using in-ears he knows you want to
be able to hear yourself exactly because
it lets you go to that tone you know
what I mean if you don't hear it then
you're trying to find it you don't know
what you sound like exactly yeah I was
just like imma just wing it and then I
figured out like yeah you need in-airs
next time
damn I have no idea he does music
that's what it is just a pack the pack
that like you know people mic you up
with when you get mic drop and go
through yeah but you've been doing huge
I'm guessing I'm assuming you guys have
been doing huge massive
performances and shows massive shows
since over 10 years now right
so it's like uh I want to say it it
started getting super crazy like 2011.
I'm like wow I remember when these fools
were like just coming up I told Mike
it's when I started moving mad packs I
was in my apartment with my my uh my
roommate and the it's before Spotify
before all that [ __ ] so I was on the
radio I was I remember I was backing up
[ __ ] I'm like this [ __ ] stealer song
again bro are you kidding me these fools
are famous as [ __ ] now or something I'm
a Packers fan that's all I kept hearing
like these [ __ ] Steelers song I
remember I was packing up packs on my
table by the refrigerator watching the
Packers no no it was it was late at
night I remember packing [ __ ] up bro and
that's the first time I ever remember
like Taylor again what the [ __ ] what did
my homies
bad time for music too because the
internet was like hindering music at
that point artists weren't getting paid
for streams and [ __ ] but they didn't
have fan bases built in like they do now
it was the end of the mixtape era at the
start of the internet era I feel like
and it wasn't I mean MGK was coming out
right around then right you had that
Waka Flocka was coming out right around
then really that's it like that D4L
style era that kind of was coming doing
that yeah yeah and it was like that you
guys had that whole sound and you guys
made weed rap cool again bro we to the
Forefront so it was like I remember that
whole time friend that was that was the
year I moved out here that's crazy no it
wasn't the year before but I vividly
remember that whole chapter of music
when you guys came out just how like it
reminded me of like when LeBron got
drafted like how big that was yeah I
mean yeah in music though yeah I mean
coming from where you know we come from
for sure it's like Corner Pocket when
you say Pittsburgh people be like oh the
Steelers that's it and that's it but
there's a lot of talent there as well
you know you just gotta get an eye on it
and they got to do the right thing to
get you to look at it so you guys were
the first in hip-hop really to like
stamp it in my mind yeah I mean first I
ever heard yeah but see that's the thing
growing up in Pittsburgh we have a
history of knowing who came to
California and put in work you know what
I mean so like
um there's a homie named mailman oh
infinite uh male man no [ __ ] Joe Beast
like a lot of there's a lot of pioneers
that came out here and we've seen that
you know what I mean so when you get a
chance an opportunity to come out here
and do some work and I don't know what
went on with their situations but if
they're not doing it any anymore
something went wrong yeah you just you
just look at that and be like yo I'ma
try to stay out there I'm gonna try to
stay in California live there work do
what I got to do not to be
for people to be asking you why you come
back what happened what happened
which is which is not really a thing
when you're working but you know that
that it's in the back it's in the yeah
it's like the Indiana Jones ball back
there like Ah that's the head of this
[ __ ] no matter what's there though right
as long as that's what you still want in
life of course of course yeah that was
my ultimate things I'm from up North I
was like man I can't move back once I
move back I I'm not gonna come back you
know what I'm saying because you know
yourself and you know like it's it's
almost like the pride like oh you
[ __ ] picking up boxes that's a
fact and it's different between
wanting to move back and having and
having absolutely oh God you know what
I'm saying then you go back and now
you're back in the mode of like now I
gotta get out of here again yeah
oh you're going back to a job you
already quit oh my God and then
everybody like you came back well yeah
just for a minute though bro I'm not
really fast though I'm not really back
I'm on my way back out short story I
failed sixth grade bro you failed sixth
grade yeah so the next time I went back
to school
they were in seventh and I was in those
same classrooms you know I I vowed to
never be in that type of situation ever
again [ __ ] bro it was
and you're tall we're tall and all the
sixth graders too
I'm like yo I'm like I'm supposed to be
going to this gym class oh but I'm going
to this gym class dominating gym class
with these sixth graders and I'm in
sixth grade again but I feel like I'm in
I'm a seventh grader so it was weird oh
damn I don't think I've ever had anybody
like no they held me back was it because
the grades you [ __ ] up oh I was
[ __ ] up I also went to a to honestly
um I went to a International Studies
Academy
so like I had to go and take a language
you know what I mean French Spanish
German what your parents do my parents
uh my mom was a secretary
my dad was a hustler that's what
happened the neighborhood School my mom
always did this the neighborhood schools
with me because I was the oldest my mom
always knew all the fighting and all the
[ __ ] that goes on at these schools
because she was a secretary for years
she was secretary for 30 years so she
knew all of the [ __ ] that was going on
in the school was literally
around the corner up the street and I
just I will walk there and kids been
doing this for years every year but with
me because I was like this star sports
player and everything she shipped me out
she was like nope you're not going to
this school and she went to the damn
school you know what I mean so but she
yeah she's like you're not going to this
school I went to a different school like
I was the guinea pig for all the stuff
that my brothers had to do after this so
because I went from the International
School to the neighborhood school after
they got to go they didn't have to go
through without it you know what I'm
saying so when high school came I wanted
to go to the school that everybody
fought at you know what I mean so she
was like nope you're not going there so
I went to another school which was a
votech where I had to take a [ __ ] uh
to a carpentry that's a good day
in your life pretty good though that's
kind of sick it's crazy like but she was
moving me around knowing that I was the
oldest this in the first so she could
see how to do with the other kids yeah
did you make the agreement we gotta
figure out I'll do it yeah I mean I
didn't really have a say-so you know
what I mean how much older are you than
the next one uh like the one down two
years and three years [ __ ] you're the
oldest yes so yeah damn you're the whole
three years in the grades too oh wait
two yeah because they held you back [ __ ]
so when I left when I was a senior and I
let I graduated from high school she let
my little brother go to the fighting
school like she was just doing a bunch
of stuff yeah just to try to like figure
it out which was cool though you know
what I mean because
um my brother like set a standard at the
school that we were at too and then he
took that to the school that he went to
so he was like Captain football team
doing all this stuff
yeah yeah for sure damn that sucks bro
come on this is a running theme on the
show now were you smoking weed while you
were playing high school basketball
senior senior year yeah
hold on did you play freshman year in
college no so but reefer took you off
the court no great SAT test took me off
to court were that was failing before
the weed though no oh technically
speaking no because it took me off the
courtroom see I still I when my senior
year when it was time to go to school to
college I had like a what 3.1 oh great
point average so I was doing good yeah
you feel me but when I went to go take
the SAT test I didn't get good scores so
when I went to my first year of college
it was prop 48 I was on probation
so I couldn't so I couldn't play I had
to go through a school year and show
that I can get the grades to be on the
team oh so I had to like make the right
grades to get off of probation so my
whole thing was
I'm going to these spring practices
watching from the fence oh like looking
over there seeing everybody in uniforms
and like seeing my homies that I'm in
the dorm with practicing and [ __ ] so
that was just discouraging to me I knew
what I had to do but seeing that just
threw me for a loop re-wrapping too yeah
I was toying around with it I wasn't
really like I didn't really care so once
I feel like I found out that I couldn't
like play I was like all right bet I
live 45 minutes away every weekend go
home ounces a week come back sell on
campus hell yeah so then the drug
selling I already knew that how to do
that you know what I mean because I seen
it like all my family was getting busy
so I was like all right cool I'm gonna
go there but I'm gonna just do it up
here like I'm just sitting up here and
see like you know I mean you don't think
you're gonna get rich on college but
everybody know the weed man any money is
Rich yes yeah anything is Rich yeah so
you're doing so you were doing good then
so your first year you just decided I'm
gonna be weed if you're gonna kick me
off the team facts good
I quit Sports a small Coach [ __ ]
like some animal [ __ ] are racist I
know he is but anyway he was Weirdo And
I I sold weed but I would hide it on
Sundays I would go in school and I hide
it in the drain pipes I'm from up North
and it's hot so it never rains so I hide
my sacks in the drain pipes and all
through school what do you want ten I'd
send my homie I'd go here and you walk
around the school come get us and I'm
gonna find our spots oh bro I crushed it
and that's what I'm saying man he's like
I stopped playing sports I'm like why
are you playing sports I'm [ __ ] going
in on this weed thing just like you just
said and they're willing to pay the top
dollar like oh wait and no one's got to
scale your [ __ ] ninth grade fifth
grade exactly you're gonna weigh it yeah
exactly [ __ ] you sell yourself you
know you know what it what it looks like
exactly
yep oh the [ __ ] but I started off yeah
hey man we're all trying to smoke for
free at that point nah I was the same
way no I I [ __ ] love it dude yeah
it's a hybrid for sure of both our lives
it really literally I was like damn this
is trippy I used to stay in the dorm
with football players and they used to
like go to class and [ __ ] then I'll just
crack the window
oh yeah going out the window should they
come back like man what are you doing
exactly so did your mom care about the
weed her she was cool with her my mom
was where I found the weed at no way I
mean anytime your mom shuts the door and
she puts a like a towel or something if
I can't see under the bottom of it
exactly I know something going on then
it started to be funny smells and [ __ ]
like that so I just traveled into a room
found a little joint that looked like
this with no filter whatsoever
trying to hit that [ __ ] yeah and you
know that's where it was really working
it's the first time you smoke weed yeah
stole your mom's roach that's the first
that's the first on this show yeah I
mean I love that and you guys are one of
the recent legal places too right
Pittsburgh it's decriminalized it's not
so [ __ ] stupid you go to The
Dispensary though right yeah they got
dispensaries there's dispensaries but
it's just decriminalized Pennsylvania is
hella weird bro is the laws are hell
aware so you can buy it and they won't
arrest you for it but it's not legal you
get a card and everything so just so if
you got the medical card oh okay all
right get it you know what I mean but if
they catch you on the street with it
your asses grass I mean anything like
under an ounce
ten years you can take it off you or
give you like a little ticket yeah yeah
that was like it used to be like that
though yeah I used to go jail yes you'd
be dumb for a small blunt yeah I've
heard the worst things about Pittsburgh
New York just went on this all last
episode oh we did uh yeah we did so real
quick so you started selling weed from
there I know you know what's the first
sack you ever sold to somebody what kind
was it no what's the first sack you ever
sold somebody like the first time you
went all right I'm gonna sell this
[ __ ] weed make money on it and have
more weed left over so I remember my
first time I ever did it was like when
those movies and you pause and then the
narration comes up and this is the first
time I've ever it was I remember
definitely a friend that you took some
notes from your mom or something like yo
you got ten dollars maybe no no I stole
weed from my cousin before but it was
like regular weed it wasn't like the
weed weed like he used to sell
he gonna kill me for this he used to
sell regular weed to old people so he
didn't really deal with like the Young
Dudes in the hood that's amazing you
know what I mean so he will always have
his customers
I used to see like 63 year old men I'd
be like where your cousin that I'll be
like they're the best they come by the
same amount the same time same day every
week I had a guy at Jim the guy from
Mississippi have you had Thomas [ __ ]
Southern that's what he said he like him
because it's the loyalty and they also
they don't be talking and yeah they're
not going to rob you they're not you
know and they work their way up that's
what I found out they work their way up
from like five seconds oh okay yeah
yeah they'd be happy as hell when they
get paid
a month later man yeah flipping their
money and she described this [ __ ] so
[ __ ] perfect he literally always did
that all right well you know with some
fives and ten
all people are [ __ ] awesome so did
the did the like weed selling escalate
once you realize you're gonna fall back
from Sports and college and all that
yeah I mean it changed into something
else you know I started selling a lot of
other things
different it's a whole different game
bro I never got into that and for like
for years I was just blind it the only
thing I cared about was phone ringing
answer that phone Serve the People go
out and party
buy guns protect yourself wake up in the
morning same thing again no I mean for
for a long time and head on a swivel
[ __ ] gets old that is what I was very
bothered by because it wasn't just it
wasn't just like the neighborhood it was
like the police as well so you got well
like it's both ways yeah bro like you
might not know about Pittsburgh either
Pittsburgh is like Buffalo basically
right like yes very much
it's super blue collar and
the police don't like you selling drugs
and [ __ ] like that yeah at all and I
would imagine like a job but Buffalo is
literally like when I lived there
completely segregated stuff by like this
side of the bridge that side of the
bridge you're on this side of town the
cops are heavily [ __ ] with you like
it's super like racial and [ __ ] like I
feel like all those cities are still
like that it's for sure because you know
and there's it's nothing racist about
this but it's it's white cops in the
community it's white task force in the
community they don't really don't come
there for no other reason like they're
not connected with the community they
don't know when they know your name they
know you from like busting you they
don't know you from like seeing you play
basketball and jump out and congratulate
you on something or come and shoot a
couple shots with you or pitch the ball
to you while you're trying to hit it
none of that bro you know what I mean so
it's like their whole thing is it's a
super divided like soup because because
they don't care for the community they
just want to [ __ ] it up so it's
different and it's like that around the
whole Pittsburgh like you might get one
black Task Force officer moving around
with six white officers but he's not
even really gonna say [ __ ] like he wants
you to get busted as well you know what
I mean he's on that same type of time
too no type of connection and that's
where the division comes in yeah and
that's why everybody in the you know
those neighborhoods take the police just
really like that that's a straight it's
a disconnect and it's like it's
Anonymous I don't care about busting you
I don't know anyone that knows you I'll
never see you again or anyone affected
by it yeah so you're the opposition
instead of like trying it's like
trolling [ __ ] online support
just think about this though yeah you're
not gonna tell me a time where you're
going to see
eight black cops on patrol ever
so man that was a crazy I just try to
imagine that [ __ ] that does not exist
exactly so it's just there's there's I
mean I'm not saying all cops are bad
because dude definitely cops that are
doing all the different cities though I
was talking about the first episode like
it's different where we're from yeah
they they're all up in your lives like
we're saying with like just random
checkpoints everywhere just like
realizing they're just following you and
they just they eyed you from a side
street now they're just kind of like
stalking you a little bit throughout the
neighborhood like that doesn't happen in
regular places like that doesn't happen
in Merced like that unless you are
straight up wearing Flags because I'm
such from a small spot
that I mean I was good I wasn't worried
about cops when I was selling packs it
was [ __ ] kicking my door in in
the night that's what I was worried
about cops over there it's more of just
they got meth heads and [ __ ] dealers
to worry about like Miss Smith
weed for me like that's why I was saying
oh you're in a different thing once you
start stop selling when you're selling
something else it's over if you're
you're you're on your head on the swivel
you're always checking your car you're
looking up every because it's over man
like anyone wants everything you got at
all times that's a fact no matter what
Thomas from the math capital of America
yeah it's bad over there up north where
I'm from but it's I mean you know where
Fresno is yeah okay it's a little town
right outside of Fresno Merced you
probably you guys definitely never
played never played there no small it's
too small did we no no way bro I'm
telling you we I I think we were there
before really oh trust me I I think we
were there before years ago it had to
have been so long
um is that where that's not where David
Carr is from oh [ __ ] yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah damn you really do know no I know
yeah yeah man that's exactly where he's
from so how many like do is there a
number like how many countries how many
like cities you've been to like if
you've been all like damn near every
continent all around the world
um not Asia no
um
is that because the weed [ __ ] you guys
didn't want to travel to Asia because
you go to jail that's the other I mean
if I got a chance to go to Asia I'm just
going to buy a battle rules for sure
about to go try to break them in another
country no especially not there yeah I
don't know how laws are like I'm not
going there to know how the laws are
figure it out from their jails to do
nothing wrong so yeah like it like Dubai
we had to fly to Dubai we had to not
smoke for like uh uh 48 hours or
something like that
that's a change yeah for sure is it a
lot of water push-ups the UFC fighters
I feel you just get bored bro yeah right
they got like
they got like hashish but you gotta like
know somebody and [ __ ] like that because
a lot of people are afraid to even yeah
do some [ __ ] over there is it tough for
you guys to just travel in general or
back in the day was it like were they
extra [ __ ] with you because you're
not busy dudes
no I mean
only places like we really get [ __ ]
with and they didn't even really [ __ ]
with you got to do it but crossing the
border to Canada oh yeah no matter what
there's always a thing because just
think about this this is this is what
people don't this is just coming from
the inside like
if we're moving on a bus with 11 people
right
and we're about to cross the border I
have no idea what tricks these 11 people
are or two of them are about to try to
do like if they're trying to bring
something yeah you know I mean you know
you're good yeah but that all runs
through my mind I'd be like who's about
to try to some [ __ ] never thought about
that you know because you guys are all
getting in trouble you know it's not
like one of you bro yeah it's all done
and then that's when you see the dog
like so this has happened to you before
yes oh [ __ ] okay so where were you at
that this happened they put the dogs in
you because obviously
the thing about it is like uh of course
like there's a night like we'll do the
show we'll do a show in another spot and
then let's just say we did a show in
Buffalo and then we got across the
border because we're so close it's the
next show because of the routing is in
Canada so we'll go that night across the
border and when we get to the Border
it's like four to five buses
so they gotta check everyone you know
what I mean but while we were doing the
show
the morning of they'll tell us no
smoking on the bus at all so it won't
smell like weed but the bus driver will
also go clean it and then come back and
then get us and then we'll cross the
border well now I'm saying but you know
some people's bags got checked there was
certain [ __ ] in there sometimes you know
sometimes they throw this [ __ ] away and
just look the other way and don't take
the people you know
so
because I could see it going either way
with like the Superstar treatment like
they must put bigger dicks to you guys
or you guys might just get away with
whatever you want like I could see it
it's 50 50. so where you're at man yeah
I never really like I mean I tried some
[ __ ] and I got away with it but yeah
that's no hair over there
I don't need nobody to know the trick
that I did to do it so there's a lot of
them and I guarantee you every cop
there's five people I know every [ __ ]
trick in the book exactly and they do
have a tutorial on the show I probably
have man I I'm my mom is very violent so
if I got caught with some [ __ ] I'm dead
you know what I'm saying especially when
she's like you better not be doing drugs
you better not because my mom had me at
so young that I was on a strict no gang
[ __ ] growing up in Gangland right which
is good because I'm [ __ ] nice and a
lot of my homies grow gangbangers so
um
I was the master of hiding [ __ ] in my
house because you know the wrath of
people and I don't know if your mom's
scared because she smoked weed
so my mom didn't smoke weed she does
mushrooms and [ __ ] she asked me for
shrooms now it's a whole different thing
now that my mom she's been on the show
oh he's high right where you're sitting
that's fire yeah but when I was a kid
she was Joe Pesci like she was [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of me for nothing so
I'm the master of hiding [ __ ] like I
used to you posted remember posters just
tack them up you know where before
[ __ ] that had frames yeah or
all the surprised in the same age right
so I used to just
put all my weed lined up behind my
posters and Tack them up and every day
right when I'm leaving the school just
take the two pins out buying it off all
free my backpack
prisoner [ __ ] yeah
that's some weed head MacGyver [ __ ] I
had to man I like that I like that what
poster was it that's not bad it was a
Cheech and Chong
but she showed me it oh okay you got to
tell him that next time I know you
shaved my ass a few times what was it oh
shout out Tommy Tron what game was it
the Rams game the Rams game this was
wrapping all of our gear he's awesome
they cut they cut to him at the Rams
game and he had his dope as usual shirts
yeah I love this didn't even ask for I
appreciate it man right he didn't even
ask to be on camera but [ __ ] yeah
exactly he didn't even ask he's just
like he was dead and it was sick as fire
yeah
what's up guys welcome to the ad break
and this episode is sponsored by Miller
Lite as you guys already know Miller
Lite is the official beer of the dope as
usual podcast Miller Lite is the beer
for beer drinkers that like the taste of
beer and not hot dog water you guys know
what I mean by that there's light beer
out there that tastes like literal trash
and then there's Miller Lite so guys
every time you drink your milk remember
you're supporting Marty and I you're
supporting this podcast thank you so
much if you're watching this podcast as
it comes out Monday Night Football is
about to start make the Monday Night
Football perfect grab Miller lights and
think of us right now you go to
millerlight.com forward slash Yola
that's gonna take you to a landing page
as always and that landing page shows
you everyone that delivers beer in your
area and if you haven't been drinking
right now go to any store on the planet
that sells beer and grab yourself a 12
pack for all the non-fat guys out there
remember 3.2 grams of carbs 96 calories
per 12 ounce can always remember guys do
not drink and drive from Marty and I on
the dove as usual podcast we preach it
all the time please don't drink and
drive so once again go to
millerlight.com forward slash Yola
that's a landing page for everyone that
delivers if not go straight to the store
celebrate responsibly from the Miller
Brewing company in Milwaukee Wisconsin
guys it's Halloween it's scary luckily
our friends at manscape just launched
their fourth generation performance
package make sure your pumpkins are
getting the ultimate carving experience
this Halloween it's hard to feel super
confident when you're [ __ ] balls are
super gross so unlock your confidence
with the performance package 4.0 we got
all the pubic products featuring
Advanced Skin safe technology starting
with the lawnmower 4.0 it's waterproof
easily the best piece of ball trimming
equipment you can buy online the big
game changer when it comes to men's
hygiene is the weed whacker from ear
hair nose hair it's skin safe no tugging
snagging nicking all that stuff is gone
with manscape you're stealing the deal
with the crop preserver bald yoderant
the crop reviver ball toner your balls
will thank you you're balling out of
control for Halloween and manscape is
not just about trimming and cutting hair
they've just introduced the new body
buffer and the body buffer is an
antibacterial body scrubber to keep
yourself clean and hygienic so right now
go to www.manscape.com forward slash
Yola 20 off of anything and everything
and free shipping to your house we're
throwing in two bonus gifts we got the
manscape boxers the manscape performance
bags again that's 20 off in free
shipping with code Yola at manscape.com
So speaking of sports
I asked Jesse he goes oh he's a real
good basketball player like damn it
Justin I called you for a reason
[ __ ] tell me something tell me
something else I couldn't just hey
Google
basketball so I used to play basketball
we talked about that
um it was a serious thing that you took
like you could have went
too much yeah first tattoo and then this
is this was remembering oh [ __ ] he's got
the N1 guys so like I thought it was hot
sauce so I understand yeah like I it was
it was crazy like I won Dunk Contest I
played in summer league got paid to play
in Summer League [ __ ] like that you know
what I mean so I took it super serious
when I was great when I graduated from
high school it was that was like 25
points a game you know what I mean but
that's what I'm saying the essay once it
once you fail that SATs wow that [ __ ]
really derailed you it like Notre Dame
came to the school like literally to the
[ __ ] um the votech high school that I
went to like to recruit like in person
you know there means some [ __ ] that
never happened at our school before
so it was like that level did you guys
have a really strong program or no damn
so they came for you man they came to
look at you then when we when I got
through with my brothers and my homies
from my neighborhood like six to eight
of us end up going to that school and we
all were like no more than three two
years apart so once we got to that
school whole dynamic changed we start
playing sports whole [ __ ] start changing
we had terrible uniforms we end up
getting Nike [ __ ] you know what I mean
like we changed the whole [ __ ] and then
two years after I [ __ ] graduate they
shut the school down and it's important
now it's like I'm like damn I wanted the
chance to go back and yeah be alumni and
have the whole little you know what I
mean so yeah they just erase your whole
school history oh out of there bro so
when I go to the South Side I got to see
the school and it's just people like
with their dogs and the [ __ ] yard and
[ __ ] that's crazy
bro it's crazy to see they kept the
stadium though that was the good thing
about where I went to high school at we
never had to travel so I went to a
public school you know it was it was
still public school so we never had to
travel to go to play football the
stadium was right there in the whole
city League played at that Stadium or
said same thing so it was like a nice
Turf and like all of that [ __ ] so
everybody played there we practiced and
played there they practice on like grass
and then played there on Saturdays but
that was like our Stadium where
everybody played so yeah that was a cool
you guys were more legit yeah that was
the cool part about it people hated us
for that too oh dude I can imagine this
is the the nice School my town they got
a [ __ ] pool now like in like a
volleyball [ __ ] like pisses you off I
would have never used it it's like yo I
could have smoked weed there at [ __ ]
during football games at night because
that's where all the bad kids go you
know during football games everyone
sneaks off to the sides right you
remember that day so basketball that was
something serious who are you looking up
to as a kid because I'm trying to based
on ages I'm like
I think I can guess but who who's your
idol as a kid because if basketball is
all you're about growing up not Michael
Jordan like everybody else I ain't
saying like like that yeah
I was like actually Scottie Pippen you
know what I mean I thought you're gonna
say like Iverson Trace McGrady Vince
Carter okay Pippin's a legit answer
that's what she Wallace when he was at
North Carolina you know what I mean like
stuff like that awfully specific yeah
super specific about it for sure yes I'm
not like that though I don't I know but
the only when I asked for basketball
party one more time what's going on here
uh I thought football heavy at
basketball I like it I'm just not going
to be here naming off 60 [ __ ] Legends
right now yeah right but Pittsburgh
didn't have a team all right so no so
who did you lean towards it wait holy
[ __ ] they don't got a team the uh
basketball yeah
um I mean when I used to like Pippin but
I still like the Knicks like I was a
Knicks fan Larry Johnson Starts Charlie
Ward
all I mean um and then I was a fan and
they got Carmelo and that was my that's
he's one of my favorite players as well
so I stuck around for that hoping that
something was going to be crazy and then
I realized how much I like Carmelo so
I'm like [ __ ] that team [ __ ] wherever
mellow goes yeah that's where I go yeah
so you know I went to Portland I went to
all the places you know what I mean I
went to all the places I mean Oklahoma
City like I was a fan of all these teams
like he was there no way right now like
I can't one thing I couldn't be was a
fan of the Lakers oh why why is that
because I'm a Trailblazer fan at heart
with Lillard you know what I mean so
that's what it goes back deep yes
it's super it's super deep for me like
you know what I mean that's that like I
really like
certain people's games and that's what
I'm attracted to when I watch it so I'm
like every play he's he's doing like
he's giving his all you know I mean
that's how I felt about mellow that's
how I feel about Liller it's a lot of
players that do that but I just like
their game personality
uh social media presence like oh damn
okay you're a fan have you ever gotten
to break this [ __ ] down to one of them
like have you ever talked to Carmelo and
been like no no you know what it's crazy
um we were in New York and they had shut
some place down I guess that we were
going to to eat
and um I was with my homie skate at the
time and his manager I think uh James
um
we went down in this little building and
it was like shut down as playing nice
music bartender still going we get down
the steps I look to the left I'm looking
at the table they didn't tell us none of
this I looked over and there's Carmelo
with like three of his homies
bro I just I don't know I went blank
like I looked over and I think we the
same age bro or like he's a little
younger than me like maybe a year or two
and I just looked over and I was like
damn that is him and I just just froze
and like went over there and they
introduced us and everybody shook hands
and I didn't say nothing oh no I didn't
say none of this [ __ ] I was supposed to
I was just every time I would like like
we had like food on the table every time
I would eat like some food I'd be like I
can't believe he said right wait you had
dinner at the table oh yeah Oh I thought
you just went and said what's up no we
sat there it was like an hour or two
just chilling bro like it was having
conversations of course we was talking
[ __ ] but I never got out none of this
[ __ ] that I wanted to say yeah I was
fanned out damn I was like told me he
was [ __ ] punching the air I know it
oh [ __ ] and I went to the hotel room was
like dude you just [ __ ] up you didn't
say none of this [ __ ] but it was cool as
[ __ ] though honestly oh of course of
course like he was chilling you're more
like
[ __ ] it up if I say some [ __ ] but I
didn't even think about that it wasn't
like that at all I just froze that's all
it was I just for on the wording what I
wanted to say I just froze I didn't want
to be like yo man I [ __ ] love your
basketball game my boy like been
following you since Syracuse I know you
went there and did the one and done and
won the championship you went to Oak
Hill like I know all of this [ __ ] what
happened I had the hotel Jersey see I
remember when you played LeBron on TV
like I remember all of that [ __ ] that's
what I was about to say
I [ __ ] it up well
yeah we'll see oh man that's man Carmelo
and LeBron came in on the same draft
class people forget that that was like
oh four that was the year I graduated
I'm pretty sure LeBron Carmelo and Darko
who just went off Into Obscurity
millibum
trash damn you guys watch basketball
because I don't know who the [ __ ] that
last night that's the last draft class I
know yeah he's trash no he went he went
before mellow yeah too yeah he was three
yeah yeah he went before Melo he was
garbage really sure garbage it was he
had to live in obscurity for his whole
career being drafted between LeBron and
Carmelo oh it never did nothing oh
that's he's like that's worse than the
sixth grade [ __ ] that's embarrassing
what I don't know
that [ __ ] sucks oh dude I had
something in my head I just it just flew
away
you [ __ ] I was wondering
completely different topic being from
Pittsburgh first of all we just found
out Christina Aguilera from Pittsburgh
yeah what the [ __ ] nobody knows about
that outskirts but yeah yeah
though right like
I mean I guess people do
you're a nice way of saying yeah the
voice of Music in Pittsburgh I mean I
guess so you get to just look it up and
look it on Google and see if her that's
it where she that's where I found it
sorry this is Pittsburgh Pennsylvania or
does it say another I said I famous
musicians from Pittsburgh she came up
okay oh [ __ ] I mean I have no idea I
want to know what her address was like
back then
oh I got you she's from a neighborhood
that's the thing wherever we can find
that out okay all right I'll do further
research figure that out I'll tell you
but did you know Mac Miller yes for the
show and do you have any like
memories or anything you'd like to
highlight because he's kind of tied into
the show just through Justin and like
yeah it's real all the [ __ ] shows and
all the [ __ ] photos of the spot and
I just but Justin q and Ryan those are
more of like those are my homies so
we're in town like oh let's go over
there let's go to his house I'm like all
right but also when he was sober like yo
let's not smoke over like dude just
invite me when he's not there because I
don't want to come over there like yo
Thomas you gotta pound me
right no he's not smoking I don't know
and they always knew that like no or
else just wait right so that that's
that's more of my show like Justin says
about he was here last week he stayed in
my house all week yeah like I see these
fools I got off the phone Ryan this
morning like we're just you know I mean
like we're more on the friend like those
are my homies and everybody else you
know it's like it's more of oh we're at
the show hey nice to see you again bro
let's smoke a joint but these fools
don't sleep at my house like we're
chilling going to their house so I think
that's more of what Marty was saying
like that whole crowd of that's how I
started like in the Wii Community [ __ ]
was at Red Rocks when they all these
ones are playing over there the first
day I met all those dudes because I was
doing like weed content and [ __ ] and
it's just weird to see like the growth
of everyone and what they're doing like
accused with Earth Gang and everybody's
doing all their thing it's just it's a
cool it's cool to see it years later you
know what I'm saying right I always say
being from Pittsburgh is that
if we were looking down on it there's a
select people that a select few people
that you can pluck and put them anywhere
and they're going to be able to be
successful and do what they got to do
and I'm not saying like that's not
everybody you know what I mean but given
the opportunity for the right people
they're going to be successful with it
and that's why like I'm proud of
somebody like you you know what I mean
because no matter what you know you know
rest in peace Mac Miller for sure he was
he set up to do exactly what he feel
whatever he wants to do honestly because
he knows how to move about that pace
anyway so he just found what he liked
the people that he liked and he's you
know not recreating but he knows what to
do he knows how to fit in perfectly yeah
um with Mac I think I met Mac when he
was like
16 Maybe
16. I think that's around the time I
think 16 or 17 is when we did uh paper
route
that was on the kids mixtape and um 2010
yeah and he was like yo
you can't have the Hustler bro like that
was my name back then here like I didn't
know how to ask you but could you you
know you know you could put a hook on
this song and I was like yeah back I put
the hook on there when I came out the
movie was like no you put a verse on it
for me you know what I mean so it was
always the cool kid at the studio always
laughing hanging out having a good time
you know what I mean so we always just
caught up we all used to catch up like
you know on Twitter and sometimes in
person because
little did he know or little did people
know I was standing with Wes for a good
while for like a year before I actually
moved moved out here
um and you know he was dating somebody
back then and [ __ ] Mac was living at
the house I mean was dating somebody
that was living at the house next door
so
I'll always see him here again I mean
passerby type [ __ ] so it was like super
sad like the day
my manager will had called me and was
like you hear about Mac and when
somebody says that to me immediately
it's like I'm already thinking yeah it's
bad you know what I mean then he gave me
the news and
that [ __ ] was super [ __ ] up you know
what I mean like I I literally had to do
like I couldn't like get back in the car
and be like oh [ __ ] let me hurry up and
go
back to the crib this is [ __ ] like I had
literally had to go do something else to
just like zone out and then once I got
back to the crib and started seeing all
the news and the internet and [ __ ] like
that it was like damn
it's crazy yeah because one of my good
homies was with him the night before
I mean so that was just like a it was a
weird time it was a weird one everybody
honestly weird as hell my birthday is
September 6th and that was September 7th
and I got midnight Justin and
everybody's calling like yeah [ __ ] it
ain't gonna come to town like yeah we
got some photo shoots and [ __ ] to do and
I wake up I'm like what the [ __ ] chicken
change so fastly eight hours right it's
a weird night it's a weird numb weird
thing for sure Still Still Still for
sure I forget a lot you still feel like
I'm still a fan I'm still a [ __ ] fan
at heart first off my first thing I ever
do with Rosie at that concert she's like
there's a guy macmill I'm like who is
that I went to pay dude uh MERS and all
them their festival and I was in the
back and I saw hundreds maybe thousands
of people rushed this stage like who the
[ __ ] is this
and I don't know any of the songs but I
saw these people [ __ ] like damn near
crying loving this [ __ ] and that's
before I do treaty I'm like who's this
[ __ ] do with afro and you know I mean
then tall ass just I didn't know these
people yet right it'll know they'd be
some of my best homies in the year but
it's just such a weird like
I think about that first thing like wow
who is this [ __ ] kid the first thing
I ever saw was like Jesus Christ and the
first people were rushing like Kendrick
Lamar's I'm like who the [ __ ] is that if
you look at it like it's crazy they're
they're age range is is younger than us
but if you look at
like the people that were like in most
dope you know what I mean you could look
at that and you see like I don't
yeah we were the blueprint you know what
I mean to how it's supposed to look so
that's and that comes from Pittsburgh
like it's like Pittsburgh on Pittsburgh
like back then we all used to be at the
same Studio
so we all seen what each other were
doing and once [ __ ] took off
whoever it was going to be in the
situation we would know how to do it so
it was like they went that way with
their group and we went this way with
our group but we were all in the same
building I'd love to hear doing the same
[ __ ] you know what I mean
as success yes every night bro like had
to take literally like take turns on
engineers and like stuff like that
trying to book out the most hours and
[ __ ] like that it was like a real
healthy competition back then so it's
cool the blueprint was like was was like
that you know what I mean once once I
think Wiz Kata you know the wave of he
already knew what he wanted to do and
I'm not saying Mac didn't but I wasn't
around Mac as much so I don't know what
he wanted to do so but I can tell about
how he put the cameraman the engineers
exactly so it was like the same thing
that Wiz had orchestrated and then Mack
that's a great Point how long had
where's been grinding music before Black
and Yellow
um
I mean I'm guessing for I met him when
he was that's what people don't know I
didn't know whiz when he was a kid so I
met him when he was like 16 17 same time
you know I met him when he was like I
think Mac was 16 and whiz was 17 at the
time you know what I mean and they both
went to the same high school I'm sure so
like I met them
kind of like similar time but I knew Liz
before me because I didn't really see
Mac at the studio until a little later
and then I started seeing him with all
his homies and [ __ ] like that after the
fact
do you know they went to the same high
school I had no idea damn so they really
like grew up together yeah like yeah
they they grew I don't know if they grew
up together yeah to a point for sure you
go to high school you spend some hours
with yeah yeah sure yeah so you figure
out who your friends are for real you
know what I mean so yeah they went to
the same high school
um
I'm pretty sure yeah they knew of each
other for sure because Mack was making
videos at the high school and I think
wiz was about to graduate at the same
time first video I saw it says la la
video on the portion of this boys like I
was like this is like a [ __ ] parallel
Dimension looks like my little brother
over here oh [ __ ] my mom's porch the
[ __ ] was crazy
yeah when I first saw like that whole
vibe of everybody it's more of like oh
these are homies that are just coming up
right now with everything um like I said
that when I heard Taylor Gang was my
homie saying shout out to saying because
he's a [ __ ] fanatic he's everything
show me every head all the scenes uh on
the mp3s downloading on [ __ ] lime
while he was going hard on
you remember those days man you guys
remember yeah
LCD and [ __ ] I was telling my kid on the
way to school today I used to go on with
the list
have kids make like the little I was
like oh you were that kid they'd circled
what they want I'm coming oh yeah that's
fine because I had a homie that did that
too he would charge you a dollar and you
had to bring the the blank CD oh damn
you did that yeah of course oh [ __ ] oh
yeah of course you wrote the songs out
for people no you just print out the
cover okay okay
DVD [ __ ] like yeah same [ __ ] damn Marty
no I just bought him at the flea market
he's from the hood bro
that was a Smack DVD error that [ __ ] I
had all that [ __ ] yeah okay yeah you
know what's up yeah all right of course
all right real quick before I forget so
that's what I was trying to say earlier
and one you got the tattoo on your arm
you are [ __ ] legitimately
when you talk about and one every damn
other episode bro I say I'm escalated
every five seconds I'm not but where did
you first see that I remember the first
time I ever watched and one I was into
basketball so heavy as a kid I used to
make you buy those [ __ ] shoes or the
shorts to get it you remember that [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] are we talking about
basically Mexico
flea markets oh no matter of fact not
eBay the East Bay oh [ __ ]
that's one thing are you internet kids
will never know the hype of seeing a new
East Bay magazine my grandma's house yes
[ __ ] let's see [ __ ] I can't afford but
I'm gonna stare at it bro I'm the same
way I was the same way oh my God and
that's where I really seen like uh I
started to get in the hoop shoes because
I just could see I can see them but I
couldn't afford them like you said
basketball shoes Oh I thought you meant
like a brand we call it Hoops like you
say you might say soda right you say
pops
[Music]
but you know what out here people get on
you so much about it but I just start
calling it by its [ __ ] I feel like a
traitor I'm like yo let me get a Coke
let me get a Pepsi oh that's smart like
a Mountain Dew all right oh man you got
a little loophole there yeah I was like
man I'm sick of this [ __ ] I moved to
Oregon with my dad and everybody says
pop in Oregon not here we say soda I
never heard someone say pop till I
[ __ ] went to school what the f what
do you keep asking for you to say Sub
sub like give me like a sandwich I've
never said my life you never said it
they don't have a sandwich a sandwich
you can call it Hoagie I heard that
first time I was in high school what the
[ __ ] you mean a hoagie I never heard
that [ __ ] in my life I'm also one for
the mexican-ass part of California I
moved to Oregon and every same pop and
my dad finally said it one day I was
like you [ __ ] traitor you mother
that's how people really feel about it
though it was just a joke because we're
the only Family Mexican family the
whitest town in Portland ever yeah
Clackamas yeah and I was like don't do
it dad don't [ __ ] change Subs are
like white people burritos too white
people burritos you [ __ ]
sub yeah it is like sub shops to Buffalo
in these cities like same [ __ ] thing
I ain't never seen anything say sub
honestly a sub shop doesn't exist in
Orange County this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is a
hoagie that's not a hoagie oh he's just
a bread that had you cut it on one side
right yeah but it's a lot more done just
like a pocket it's like in the pocket
damn you guys know what the [ __ ] you're
doing because I've never our food sucks
over here bro we're like a Melting Pot
of like you got okay Mexican food over
here we got good Mexican food over here
and then there's sandwiches yeah it's
pretty much California so no the M1
thing came just in in high school too
like I was watching it of course the
DVDs and [ __ ] like that yeah and uh Ali
Mo the rest in peace was my favorite
player so that's where that whole and
one
[Music]
um water shoes the basketball camp had
my mom buy me the shoes and [ __ ] like
that I really thought I was gonna get on
that DVD back then dude I think we all
did yeah I was the smallest guy here and
I even I thought like they need a brown
kid on there come on I'm over here doing
the balls
yeah I can't [ __ ] shoot threes but I
can Juke the [ __ ] out of people cause
I'm short
okay
I let the professor come in like he is
on a different level sir that is a whole
different statement thank you for
including me in the same league as the
professor I think I could fake him out
if I would look over there [ __ ]
and I'll run yeah
he pops up on my recommended because
they know they know I want to watch that
[ __ ] he did what he was supposed to
Parlay that [ __ ] into just being you
forever like yeah it's just him uh my
fiance Rosie when during quarantine she
had never seen and one and I let her
start from episode one that yeah oh I
forgot the one vlogginess of that [ __ ]
they're going tour tour and then season
or like episode five like oh there's
fans yeah there's fans forming and
they're like dude
I mean it was touring it was crazy it
was like tour but with basketball don't
that's where I learned how to do
montages I think oh when you're editing
think about it they were doing Vlog
montages they were doing Vlogs for
YouTube and one started that VH1 life uh
true life follow me on the road type
Behind the Music it was Air1 oh I love
that [ __ ] I never realized I guarantee
my grandma still got my DVDs
damn can you go buy DVD players now
still this PlayStation vintage
PlayStation oh yeah yeah you don't even
I don't know where you could buy a DVD
player yeah I just wanted to just check
and see I found my vhs's the other day
I only got home alone Batman
returns and Space Jam I don't own any
VHS I had to keep those remember from
McDonald's I used to go to McDonald's
you can get uh the tapes
um
I don't remember that yeah was it the
full movies yeah on VHS like when
Wayne's broken I'm a blockbuster ah see
I went to McDonald's my grandma it's six
dollars and you can buy Batman we didn't
have McDonald's yeah damn I have it in
my house I'll just send you a picture of
this [ __ ] yeah that didn't happen that's
crazy damn nobody why do I feel like a
lonely [ __ ] that remembers this
[ __ ] I don't know maybe it's just Merced
maybe some bootleg ask for a second I
don't know yeah that was like some
off-brand [ __ ] they were just slanging
themselves probably now would you
consider yourself a weed snob are you
super like particular about
what you get not snob I just know what I
don't want and know what I do want and I
experimented with [ __ ] and I know what I
like and what I don't like so what do
you usually go for OG all day joints
simple yeah same all day every day
I don't care if I'm tired I don't know a
lot of people like you're sleepy else
I'm like yeah I know but I don't smoke
hybrids I'm good yeah they'll [ __ ] them
up for a week where's my direction and
there's certain people that I get around
that I I really I know they did they're
like picky about their weed too so I
don't I don't mind smoking with them so
like burner of course clean weed with
whiz of course
um my brother you know what I mean both
my brothers actually little brother oh
okay I didn't even ask me always asks
what do they do now
um my little brother actually lives out
here who actually lived together and he
works alongside me and Wiz and the rest
of the Taylor gang no [ __ ] multiple
things you know what I mean so yeah but
he's a wee head bro like I don't I
sometimes I don't be understanding
that confident in there
all of that I knew it's like he's out
there like that means he's dabbing he's
got the timers he's the hatchback yeah
all of that I don't [ __ ]
I get it I just
all my homies are in this industry so
it's like yo let me try that [ __ ]
concentrate juice nectar you just well
he was like that too but it's almost
like a good thing now because he was
smoking those fat ass joints I
constantly throughout the day of OG
right now he just takes a little couple
yeah I just take hella dabs throughout
the day for the past rips off the cards
but I think it's the weed I can always
do this bro dabs are just not me they
put you out it's pretty much your day's
over yeah I've seen too many people like
you see the one in the in the smoke shop
where the guy goes through the uh
we container at the dispensary see what
I'm saying like uh I passed that up a
dab too so that flower right there isn't
that weed not gonna make you do that no
you wait
real quick you ain't never got the cough
so hard you you have to like pause you
never got that off the weed
um you're gonna smoke bongs then huh
hear it now you're just a joint smoker
though yeah I do oh then you know what
you want there it is yeah you know
exactly what you want to smoke yeah
um do you have anything else coming out
soon
um I just started getting back in the
studio
uh I took just took some time off to
gather up some beats and actually write
some music
um yeah I just been in the studio
um I've been gaming like I said
where can everybody watch that Chevy
Woods 4800 is it 4800 so like four eight
zero zero not the word okay good we'll
pop we'll pop it up on the screen yeah
so but uh so you're saying you've been
on Twitch heavy are you there every week
yeah oh [ __ ] so like I mean of course I
was on tour and what I did on tour was I
just pulled out my phone and started
using the twitch you know what I mean
and like giving people writing in the
city in the title and show number one
show number two showing up and just
giving them backstage then wanted then
what shows going on show some of this
[ __ ] BTS yeah so you gotta like you got
to stay engaged over there you know what
I'm saying so if you soon if you like so
in my mind I was thinking I'm about to
go on tour how the [ __ ] am I going to
talk to these people and I just started
you know what I mean so like I was
getting only like 12 to 14 viewers
viewers in the chat time so I was like
how the [ __ ] am I gonna build that up
and still stay connected so I started
doing on tour [ __ ] and that [ __ ] started
to get me more followers I think it's
like 2500 3 000 right now [ __ ] yeah is
it twitch people or people coming from
Instagram to your Twitter so people that
come from other social medias for me
how I think is that they're just
watching they're not becoming a part of
it fully yet because they just want to
see it the people that are really there
they know what this is already you know
what I mean so they're automatic
subscribe follow oh I got one those
other people you gotta tell them they
gotta see it in the nightbot gotta write
it in there like they go oh you know you
do all that [ __ ] I see those on the
stream bot said this oh I need to get my
[ __ ] set up so it's like telling people
to join a Discord get my album get music
and I mean follow this follow that let
you know when we're doing like giveaways
or whatever like all of that [ __ ] is set
up and that's through Discord shout out
my homie Dave shout out my homie Dre
shout out my homie Banks
I had no idea bro you know what I mean
like my little my younger brother put me
on this and then I started seeing the T
Grizzly [ __ ] now somebody went on the
interview and told you that they made
like what 200k in a month off a [ __ ]
video game
you won't go get a video game stop hell
yeah you can take a shot at it that's
the thing about it for me you know what
I mean that's the thing I don't I don't
it might not be 200k but what if it's
50k what if it's 25k anything positive
and if you're having fun oh [ __ ] my bank
account grew I think it's worth it and
you're not having to do extra [ __ ]
that's what's wrong people just and then
there's there's some and then people
like there's sometimes I have the camera
on then there's sometimes where I want
them to see the whole thing so they just
see my character you know what I mean
then if sometimes I'm more in war zone
and I got the camera on and they see my
reaction to when somebody shoot me or
some [ __ ] they clip it they take it post
it somewhere and it's funny then it
becomes something on social media yeah
then somebody's looking at the bottom of
the screen like oh whose page is this
then they go over twitch and start
following the stories and [ __ ] like
everything like Cycles itself yeah and
not just gaming like I'll go over there
when I leave the studio the next morning
or the next afternoon or whatever I
might just put the twitch on just to
play the song that I just did and just
let people hear where I'm going and I
said like I'm just having conversation
then I switch the title to just chatting
then I switch back to Warzone then I
switch back to you know what I mean how
long have you been doing this for
um I had twitch for a long time but I
never knew how lucrative it was and I
never knew how accepting the community
is you know what I mean so if when you
get over there and you're like there on
a daily basis they want to talk on a
daily basis these kids and these
grown-ups as well are buying the games
that you buy buying a merch coming to
the shows you know what I mean like
actually Community I'm meeting people
that I'm working with like so it's
Taylor game gaming and we have staff you
know what I mean so the staff is just in
the Discord so we built this without
even seeing each other oh you know what
I mean so interesting when I went on
tour though I made sure that when I was
in their cities come out to the show we
gonna meet blah blah blah take pictures
whatever Bust It Up smoke he's doing the
same [ __ ] right now exact same thing
it's about to go on tour they did the
Discord they just did our first little
stop this past weekend you know Chicago
this weekend but it's a cute Community I
met people like yo I'm so-and-so from
the chat but oh with the little icon
with the thing like yeah yeah exactly
and that's what you do it for you know I
mean it's just building the community
like that because
also what we what we're doing is what we
already been doing it we give them
there's like a a Taylor Gang stream
channel
so everybody's getting a chance to
promote their [ __ ] where they're turning
their [ __ ] twitch on and they're
getting two viewers now they're getting
25
50 of us
being in there making it in like
something you know what I mean so
they're getting that's a smart system
as well right there's a Food Channel
there's a weed Channel there's a it's a
whole Discord full of like [ __ ] that
we're doing so next we're starting with
the giveaway soon so
it's it's building it's wizard gamer too
nah he's not but he just yesterday did
follow the uh Instagram Taylor Gang gave
me Instagram and when I put that in the
in the chat for them they didn't see it
they would they went crazy you know what
I mean so like they're like yeah all
right but that's awesome yeah oh yeah
and then the cooking I see I've we've
watched the [ __ ] that you've been doing
like videos on cooking so is this
something that you is this like a a
twitch thing like a hobby that you're
just trying to
show everyone or is it something that
you saw like you know what I think I'd
be good at doing cooking [ __ ] no I've
been cooking I've been I mean without
the camera yeah for sure for sure for
that I'm saying like as in the idea for
the show you're like you know I'm just
going to record myself no I can't no
that came with the pandemic oh another
way of me saying to myself like the tour
[ __ ] with the twitch [ __ ] is how am I
gonna reach the fans now that I can't be
outside so that's where the Cooking
Channel came in I was like oh I could do
this still have the cameraman come over
and shoot and [ __ ] like that with a mask
on and all that [ __ ] at the time and we
were doing that show too yeah and still
get the [ __ ] done so that's why 10
episodes got done on the first season I
think we're on episode four now I'm
about to start finishing the rest of it
and we're gonna do medicating for it all
yeah Michelle
we allowed to talk about that
we allowed to talk about that medicated
food stuff
my bad
yeah so yeah yeah yeah we're we're
something's going on nice work on his
face like something's happening all
right I'm gonna just keep it that way
that's the best way to put it you smile
and go you'll see yeah that's when you
know you're like oh it's sealed I mean I
had to ask first just to be sure but
yeah
it wasn't too short so yeah I'll just
keep that in them just leave it like
that until it is what it is man you're a
great example of like really just taking
like that fan base and just spreading it
out in all different ways and things
that you like and like making it make
sense for you in a way that it's like
okay I actually want to do this it makes
sense within my data make time for all
those and it like gives back to your
fans and kind of feeds itself right
that's how
entrepreneurs do it yeah I was just
talking to a friend anybody that really
cared during the pandemic and just put
out content as soon as the pandemic's
over I guarantee all of them felt it
like all my community is strong as [ __ ]
yeah for sure everybody felt like they
were
I mean you too I know you recognize
people's name hey man how was that [ __ ]
you said you were going to a [ __ ] job
interview yesterday and you see him in
the chat again it's like
virtual it's like pen pals now like when
you were a kid you had a hell of homies
like it's like going to summer camp
every time you get in that chat like yo
what's up oh you got that job good [ __ ]
oh you got a new car
right oh man it's it's different
especially during the pandemic it's made
everybody come together because everyone
was in the same [ __ ] boat of are we
gonna die tomorrow now we're good okay I
still watch this [ __ ] you know
what I mean everybody got Tighter and
well staring at the walls was so bad
like you just had to be in the house
looking at these walls of course it's
like it's not you know incarceration no
no because you you're free like but at
the same time like I feel like I was
about to be bouncing off all of the
[ __ ] like it was weird for me
to feel like damn martial law might go
down that's all that's what I was like
even driving back from LA to Orange
County a couple times I'm like damn
there's gonna be [ __ ] tanks out here
one of these times that's I was as long
as that didn't happen I was good yeah
um where can everybody find you on uh
YouTube the Chevy Woods everywhere yep
Chevy was everything
twitch 48 4800 which is Chevy 4800 4800
shout out to the a-hole that won't let
me get my name oh you got one of those
oh I have periods and [ __ ] on Twitter
it's like why would you want to I mean
if well we're living in a different time
now because there's people getting paid
off of being somebody else oh for sure
so he knows oh yeah I can't even say
that but I was gonna say why would you
want to be somebody else because people
getting money
got deleted off of uh Instagram almost
30 times now almost a month I'm on what
account 28 right now right
and there's about 40 to 50 fake pages I
mean just telegram packs here's pill
well not delete those pages yeah it'll
be that's being an [ __ ] they're not
going to do it they're not going to
delete the pages that are selling
but they delete me every month it seems
like I've had this page for two months
now though so
we'll see man that's weird bro it is
weird it's a weird space like my first
Instagram name was Chevy bags at first
and then
of course my goofy ass thought it was
something different you know what I mean
than Twitter and you're not supposed to
connect it you know what I mean so I
just had separate you know what I mean
yeah exactly and then of course it
clicked in like oh you're supposed to be
the the same person there over here
trying and I did the same thing too I
used the name for [ __ ] Anchorman
everybody like your name's Brian I go
why why do you [ __ ] think oh yeah
yeah so I I that social media [ __ ]
didn't happen until recently so I get
you
um no dude I just want to say thank you
so much for coming thank you for taking
the time to come out here and uh smoking
it up appreciate you actually finish
this off
um so next you're working on your next
project right now everybody can follow
you at Chevy Woods everywhere except
twitch Chevy Woods 4800
all right yes sir why do you have
anything else you want to add you guys
are big in the UFC right or no yeah I
mean I watch it a lot oh you do yeah you
got like a favorite fighter top three
style Bender bro all right oh that's the
that's the guy yeah yeah we're trying to
get him yeah yeah yeah yeah
I don't want to [ __ ] that name up he's
got a fight coming up right or no is it
in Dubai coming up or no I'm not sure
I'm real indecisive about this I think
it might be I think it might be I think
it's on fighter Allen is that what
that's what they call it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we we've never been
to one but oh I know we gotta go man
we're finally like all right let's go
and I looked and there's not a [ __ ]
UFC in anywhere near here for the rest
of the year
you know but yeah we had a couple USC
guys coming on soon I'm excited I'm
excited you ever been a boxing match not
in person no I haven't seen any of that
[ __ ] dude Bros it's valid yeah yeah I
feel like I [ __ ] up not going to bed if
you ever get it if you ever get a chance
on on YouTube look at Badu Jack like
b-a-d-u Jack and put cut open oh
bro yeah we were there bro wait is this
recent this was maybe like three years
ago oh yeah I'll tell you how about the
three or four years ago
just look at it bro horrible I'm talking
about from boxing gloves and maybe like
a head button or something but his [ __ ]
was like bro I'm talking about when the
punchline he was still fighting was that
open bro he's hit a mass of blood yeah
when the punch hit
it's like it went out like raging
bullets right like like I was bright
cold Sprites
it was like that's the description down
I'm telling you about USC fights might
be different because it's a little more
like enclosed but the boxes it goes
straight out like soon as you oh my God
I never thought about that like the most
famous people sit right at the oh Lord
on them before bro
I never thought about that [ __ ] yeah the
movie stars damn do you go to UFC's
I've been to Bellator oh sick yes I've
been to Bellingham I need to go to
psychics I do is where's still training
MMA mm-hmm yeah that's like I saw
somebody like challenge him to a boxing
match or some [ __ ] I'm like I don't I'm
not gonna happen yeah you got to be I
mean yeah
MMA for some years now some people do it
for their self for their peace for their
you know what I mean yeah of course
sanity you know what I mean for defense
especially to exercise that's all it's
for it's like I'm walking to the store
get away from me it's not on offense
like I'm gonna go look for somebody to
do this too nah of course yeah I think
that's most people like yeah most people
that are in them but nah you got some
[ __ ] out there oh for sure you
[ __ ] leave the gym jacked up after
they did it and be like I'm going to the
bar tonight I know a couple of them
pushing and you know your child and put
somebody in the head lock that ain't
supposed to be you know
you know boxers hands are registered
right yeah that shit's sad yeah so like
UFC I don't know how that works hold on
is that a fact yeah is that a myth no
that's real those are weapons yeah
that's a song that's a fact yes I didn't
know in my mind I've never known if that
was real or not you got to register your
hands if you're that's a bad ass
why you think they got a committee
Las Vegas got that whole committee for
boxing oh to register you in oh I can't
even think about it like that before we
get out of here real quick yep you guys
know uh speaking of fighting you guys
know Tom Hardy the actor you got to play
Bane and [ __ ] yeah
that [ __ ] just entered the open
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu World Championship
in one damn for real is he actually a
big guy out of that I don't know man he
looks like he's probably like six foot
but he's a pretty big [ __ ] but
it shows him winning in the ghee and
everything and he's all bearded and [ __ ]
damn this [ __ ] open just went in
the open uh competition and won the
whole thing it's full circle I'm good
that's that's a good spin-off for your
new movie you know the Batman movie you
know what stadium he did that to right
remember him in the stadium where he
blew that [ __ ] up yeah when the when the
football player was running and [ __ ]
that was a harness feel was it yes was
it really yes man why did they pick that
city of all cities what the [ __ ] you
mean why would they want to blow up
Steelers spot I don't get it
I mean I think is that what you're
saying no you know that movie some of
that movie was actually just shot and
picked it was shot oh I had no idea is
it look like Gotham over there
yes I'm a downtown definitely does yeah
yeah so it was the movie was shot some
of it over there he looked up she was
like was there any movies ever filmed in
Pittsburgh is that gonna marry Zach and
me are making porno that's exactly what
I brought up that's where the use the
[ __ ] school they used yeah that's the
high school I went to no [ __ ] damn
that's that and they met and the the
funniest thing is right
they like I lived on like two streets
this summer ended off with it I lived
like two streets down from there it was
snowed out so how is how it's snowing
for real in the beginning when they're
just flying in the car it was really
like that but they put trailers in front
of our houses they put [ __ ] on the doors
like no cars park like they bought the
[ __ ] like from the city like no matter
if you [ __ ] if you was like renting
houses there it doesn't matter get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you owned a house they
wasn't gonna do [ __ ] but if you was
renting a house like they figured all
this [ __ ] out whose doors to put the
[ __ ] on and not all of that [ __ ] movies
go deep Bro they do it right here too
yeah because of course this is the
biggest place to do that [ __ ] but they
were they were like these are like side
streets like little in a little
neighborhood bro and like uh they made
it seem like they were going to like a
far out
high school that [ __ ] was across the
street where they were [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of here so when you seen the car
drive up the driveway
the the [ __ ] came from right there at
the bottom of the hill easiest film [ __ ]
ever then that's it's smart camera super
smart yeah they know what they're doing
yeah right they said Dave's doing it
like that oh yeah
well dude thank you so much for being
here we appreciate you having me bro
everybody Chevy Woods everywhere Chevy
Woods four eight zero zero twitch
appreciate you man thank you so much for
being here
have fun yes sir thank you guys it's
been another episode of the dove as
usual podcast have a dope ass day
all right I'm surprisingly pretty high
off two joints
two
oh
what is that
thank you guys appreciate it
oh man yo I've been trying to get Justin
but I don't want to say put him on blast
too hard that [ __ ]
[Music]